c'est très très simple l'Ukraine s'est
réveillée sous une pluie de bombe
russeilomé oui absolument je me trouve
en en ce moment même sur les lieux d'une
de ces frappes vous n'en voyez pas les
images puisque selon les directives
militaires nous ne pouvons pas montrer
le lieu de l'impact tant que les secours
sont encore actifs sur place pendant les
premières heures suivant cette frappe
qui s'est réveillé après plusieurs
alertes aériennes dans la nuit dernière
sous une pluie d'explosion alors je
rappelle que même si les missiles
n'atteignent pas forcément leurs cibles
les débris forcément ils font également
des dégâts on parle de bombes de
plusieurs tonnes qui tombe sur des
bâtiments résidentiels c'est t le cas où
je me trouve à lukaniska c'est un
quartier de Kief où la station de métro
a été endommagé ou un entrepôt semble
avoir pris feu de ce que je peux vous
dire il y a une énorme colonne de fumée
noir qui s'élève les habitants et bien
ils regardent autour de moi ils
regardent ce qui est en train de se
passer il y a du trafic parce qu' qu' a
les gens qui continuent d'aller au
travail malgré tout donc c'est assez
irréel à voir et vous mentionnez ces
frappes elles ont également touché
d'autres endroits dans le pays un
hôpital a été touché à halkiv dans le
Nord Est du pays ad nipllo c'est un
centre commercial et une maternité qui
ont été touchés et elles vivent dans
l'ouest du pays et bien ce sont des
bâtiments résidentiels qui ont été
touchés partout il y a des blessés on n
pas encore le bilan mais de ce que je
peux vous dire de ce que je vois là où
je suis il y a des douzaines
d'ambulances sur place donc c'est une
une nouvelle attaque d'ampleur que la
Russie a lancé contre l'Ukraine aux
premières heures du jour Emmanuel chaza
Kiev merci beaucoup on vous retrouve
dans nos éditions tout au long de la
journée sur France 24